well hello guys and gals Mary here i'm
here with alexa we're both pretty big
fans of Freddie's faz bar pizzeria yeah
we both played through the first one
lots of laughs lots of scares mostly
scared mostly scares and I can't handle
animatronics it's intense and this is
the second one I have not played it I
haven't seen anything from it I heard
you so we're going into this blind fly
so be really exciting and we're gonna do
together soon here we go starting again
I'm a little nervous me too I'm actually
more than one Armas oh gosh the grand
the governing I can't handle the duck
yes I'm about that's a thief right okay
there's three that's great all right
let's say okay sounds we have multiple
things we need to keep an eye on um
music box one these three hole [ __ ]
right there I'm on mouse but Alexis on
flash like a flash light so email like
every now and again will the flashlight
scare them so that I think it just
illuminates them
thank you God what boys like oh my god
I'm gonna kill him but that meal a [ __ ]
oh no family okay he's definitely not
young he's not there anymore okay okay
Oh
they're all gone they're all moving much
pleasure they're all gone oshkosh trying
i can't i think it worked but what oh
you guys hope it doesn't Holden ezybox I
have to wonder oh you flash flash flash
flash right there flash flash flash oh
you can use the flashlight in all the
room ok does that keep them from being
what what what what did i miss clash
Bachchan was like he's standing in the
in the party rooms are there oh I
Oh
Oh was that noise
all of these works okay don't worry it's
fine we do way just wash it or it was
waiting on I think we have to wait I we
have to stop it coughing I got take it
off ok ok ok wait volunteers someone's
here at home dear oh my god can't maybe
box ok is he gone yeah I guess ok come
on Freddy Go the furnace do it whoever
[ __ ] up my life like Lily's going
come on going wait what why is that
there why is that there who is what I
the Linux I'm trying oh my god it's okay
it's not why why because I there why is
this little [ __ ] can we knock it out we
just bought can you invent visit the
trick won't work on it way thing
oh what was that oh I almost vomited oh
my god a child lives in a little thing
flew out a does that look like a thing
another face with a face I think you're
not very descriptive when you're scared
it was a face there's the thing the
thing with the thing you think was
amazing oh that's creepy as [ __ ] kids
Cove thing oh all right
there that's what that Miss [ __ ]
there Jesus all right so let us keep an
eye on that yeah sorry i'm just kind of
creeping around as you do and children
party facilities you'll work we're
really good lurkers the rabbit the
[ __ ] rabbit's gone sorry okay okay
that's okay security guards are allowed
to cuss he's still there whoa okay it's
so that rabbit is like super aggressive
wait okay what sorry I'm clicking around
real fast that's how i do this i click
real fast I'm hoping that like those
older models don't actually don't know
ever they probably moved because I mean
you're playing the wrong game if you're
like I really hope those things don't
want to kill me oh god I hear him hear
him I hear him to do it just put it on I
don't know but like I can't oh my god oh
[ __ ] serious oh my god damn it so we
know that that sound is the Fox
the banging go away I don't know what 20
is that enough I mean really gone now I
don't know maybe do kill me check the
other things like maybe hit the music
box I don't know sure do we have time
have to we can't i'm down 1 f'n battery
here it is too may em we're smart wow I
hope they pay this pay us really well
it's for whoa what it was a head on the
floor okay yeah I was like Hank blue
guys still there balloon Eric I think I
hate balloon by the most okay he's in
the party room 3 okay good oh that
wasn't there before okay flashlight all
right okay okay okay okay
what should we do I don't know I mean we
can either take it off and flashlights
or check out all my guys still there
still there still there all right we're
screwed I mean we could I heard she's
never got here we go here we go I hear
walking fox fox fox oh my god it won't
okay fox fox fox [ __ ] okay okay that's
all right I've got a lot flashlight oh
no yo [ __ ] where did that come from what
was that no no I think it was a
jack-in-the-box why is there a jack in
the Oh like that's why the wine thought
the music okay so if we don't whine the
music jobs in the jack in the box is a
present jumps in our veins of it skip I
think we need to keep the box at full
all the time that way give me a little
fox light what does the Fox say
wake up the box at bay give me a little
fox light box light okay okay good yeah
okay balloon guys still there wind up
box winding winding forever balloon guy
go there the Prophet the rabbit the
rabbit oh my god oh the duck is moving
by flesh the duck is all that do
anything I don't know father there the
tuckus is all I can't I can't deal with
the death of teeth like a car do it
please leave please go away Doug with
teeth I don't like you oh oh oh my god I
haven't checked on the zune guy I've
been checked on the new guy a press
check on the blender
we didn't check on the balloon guy hey
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay okay [ __ ] he's gone below
guys know me all right all right wait
flashlight I can't why can't I use it
why can't I NJ / like I'm trying oh my
god it I'm trying to use it what would
you staying in this comfy little home
definitely felt 4x the utter took it off
reflection / nothing
I happened to go scared I'm so nobody
[ __ ] okay thank you for your thing do
you think thanks Foxxy budget do you
think that's enough everybody hold
airless Oh your mommy's coming here to
worry caravans airman I heard it through
years I heard call me photo oh my god I
don't know what you want to try flash
look I think did get that [ __ ] music
box holy [ __ ] okay ah good put it on
hieronymus ok I saw the parrot the pears
in the roof the Bears
terrible night time where the worse